I'm basically gonna speak about
relationship building and the IT
community so the first thing I'll say is
a lot of us can be really shy or
introverts here in the community
I took the myers-briggs test in college
and I came back about as introvert as
you can possibly come back and I have
lots and lots of friends and the Tecla
home and community my husband who's
actually at my desk right now at start
spaced 46 he's actually really shy he
also has a relationships and the IT
community so you can be shy you can be
an introvert you can still build lots of
relationships and part of the thing
about building relationships and the
Takahama community it's about building
real genuine relationships sometimes you
go to events that aren't for IT and it's
about networking it's kind of awkward
and you don't know how to talk to you
it's a lot of really great people here
in the community that you can build
relationships with so real quick why
would you want to build relationships
one it can be really fun you can also
learn your skills faster and then it
might also help you find a job later so
just for fun we've got a lot of people
here for example they're trying to learn
web development they either want to
become a developer or you're are you a
developer you kind of got something
already built in but you might find
someone that also like star gate or star
chart discovery or some kind of other
interests that you have
another thing it can help you learn your
skills faster so for example Jesse
Harlan Tech Lahoma Foundation president
he's really amazing with JavaScript we
first met actually at a sequel event
actually we started chatting and he
actually helped me out with some
JavaScript with jQuery when jQuery was
really popular so you can also like
learn your skills faster and then also
it can help you in your job search so
you're looking for a new job or you're
looking for that first job you can start
asking people hey you know I'm looking
for a job what are some of the really
awesome companies to work for in
Oklahoma City or Tulsa or wherever
you're looking or if it's someone that
knows you pretty well
hey what places do you think would be a
great fit for me we're gonna hear a
presentation later talking about the
right company for you there are so many
different sized companies there are
different cultures and different sized
companies that are right fits for people
so that's a conversation that you can
get
going now one thing I would say with
respect to resumes I would typically let
someone offer to take your resume and
pass it around it can be kind of an
awkward conversation if someone is like
hey Kristen I know you work out such and
such company and could you pass my
resume along I've actually had that
happen like at a sunday-school before
was someone that I had never met before
and they were wanting me to pass their
resume along and the first impression I
got from them as they might not be a
right culture fit for the company was
that so it was kind of an awkward
conversation it also may have someone
hey they work at a company a you want to
work at company a they may be thinking
company is horrible they want to leave
Company A and they may not want to pass
your resume along because they don't
think you're a good fit there because
they don't like the company so that's
one thing I would say with the resumes
is you you potentially will have people
offered it past your resume along but I
would say that's kind of the one thing
let someone volunteer to do that for you
now on the note 4 job search my last
three corporate jobs that I have had all
came through people I knew one of them
was people I knew from a previous
employer
they loved where they're at they were
trying to recruit me when I was looking
to leave where I was that gave them a
call when they had an opening they gave
me a call like the position was pretty
much mine to lose at that point the
second case was a case where it was
actually a recruiter from a staffing
firm that you'll see that will sponsor
some events in this case she went to on
to work to deafen energy I was
interested in working at Devon energy
gave her a call and she pretty much took
my resume went past the first screen
immediately to the hiring manager and
then my most recent corporate job that I
was act cuz now I have my own
consultancy was someone that I'd known
in the community for more than 10 years
like before it was even the type of home
and community he took my resume and
passed it along so the people that you
know can be great resources for helping
him find a job even though that's not
why we're really building the
relationships long-term you can have
those conversations so how can you build
relationships if you're new
one of the things that meet ups is that
I oftentimes try to do is set next to
people that I've never met before so I
sat next to Marcus in the back had a
great conversation with him
I hadn't met him before that was really
great I could have sat next to Kimberly
who I've known for several years but
that I wouldn't have met anyone else
knew I'm Kimberly and I can talk on
slack whenever we want to so that's one
of the things I try to do a conferences
which can be a little bit bigger also
sitting people the next to that you
don't know it can be really beneficial
now one thing for people that are new or
not new that's kind of starting to take
hold at conferences is people are coming
up with the idea of basically forming a
u so if you've got like Kimberly and I
and Carson I believe like if we were
having conversation and we wanted like
all their people to join our
conversation we would like I guess in
our case form a triangle but kind of
like a you that would show hey we've got
space in our group so you can come up
and join that conversation if two more
people join that conversation then we'd
former you make sure we don't have a
circle so that new people can come up so
I'd safe here at a conference definitely
look for people that are in that you
format and if you're someone that's not
new to conferences and you want people
to come up and join your group I'd
highly recommend for me in that use so
that you can have more people come up
and talk to you so that's basically my
talk on building relationships